baby kiran's life had only just begun
he was on one of his first trips out
when his pram
was hit by a car ribbons now mark the
place where he was killed
his family gathered in shock and
disbelief to lay tributes
among the many flowers and cards a
message from his parents
always be happy it read
mommies and daddy's hearts will always
ache we love you more than
anything they said we didn't get to keep
you for long
but we're happy we had the chance to
meet you look after you
and call you our son fly high angel
kyran and his family were on the
pavement when a white bmw
and ford collided with the bmw ending up
on the path
his pram was trapped between the car and
the wall
kyren was taken to hospital but sadly
couldn't be saved
his mum was also injured in the crash
relatives are left grieving the loss of
a little boy
whose arrival just two weeks ago had
brought so much joy
with a flat very close family very close
family
you know then we need to he said he
tripped us all apart
you know but we've all got to stop you
know stay strong
we just got to be strong we just we just
called we stopped breaking
breaking the crash happened on the busy
high street in brown
hills in the west midlands a short time
later a man was arrested
four miles away in block switch
thirty-four-year-old james paul davis
from walsall has now been charged with
causing death by dangerous driving
as well as causing death by driving
while uninsured
and failing to stop at the scene of a
collision
the death of such a young baby has left
the whole community here
in shock she's just heartbreaking you
know
just horrific you think you're safe
walking along the pavement and it's just
it's horrible fly high kyran
you didn't deserve this his parents
wrote
sleep tight rest easy our baby boy
becky johnson sky news brown hills in
the west midlands